- We just hired our first
chief creative officer.
I spent six months trying to
find the person and this was the
order of what mattered to me:
first, emotional intelligence.
When I tell you that I don't
respect talent,
it would upset you.
It's stunning when I run my
business how secondary pure
talent is to people skills.
This notion that some creative
is so fucking special that they
can be a douche bag and fuck
up the entire place is the
stupidest shit I've
ever heard in my life.
And I'm very unpopular in
tech-land, I did it again at
South-By where I was
like, "Fuck Steve Jobs."
I don't want to run a business
where being mean brings
the best out of.
I don't give a shit if
you're a creative genius.
Fucking act like a
normal person, you asshole.
(laughter)
I believe continuity
trumps everything.
Continuity, you know, it's just
like sports. A team that stays
together usually beats a team
with superstars that were put
together for one season.
And I believe that.
And I love continuity at Vayner.
We have enormous continuity
already for a young company and
I want to keep it
forever because I give a shit.
Rhys is now living in London,
she's going to be part of the
London team because four years
ago when she started working for
me I'm like,
"What do you want?"
She's like "I want
to be in London."
I'm like, "Cool, if we ever go
there, you'll go there,"
and then I did it.
And by the way, I don't care
if you're driven by money or by
work-life balance or by creative
output I individually at 650
care about what you care about
and I also know when you get
married you're going to
care about different shit.
We're an HR driven organization.
I needed to find a CCO that
understood that so
that was a challenge.
Especially when you're looking
for them and I was looking for
somebody from a world like this
because I wanted to taste what a
seasoned veteran from a Widen,
from a Crispin looked like.
What did that feel
like internally?
(light music)